un nouveau schéma du maintien de l'ordre
a été présenté hier en partie par le
gouvernement la première mouture de
septembre 2020 avait été retoquée par le
conseil d'état est fortement critiqué
par les journalistes on va en parler
tout de suite avec notre journaliste web
antoine boitel crt sur le web
[Musique]
bonjour antoine on est ravi de vous
avoir dans cette matinale verte et
france alors on l'a dit le schéma
national de maintien de l'ordre appelées
également le snm où on s'en souvient
c'est ce document que qui a été produit
par par beauvau qui avait été retoqué
par le conseil d'état en juin 2021 à
présent donc le gouvernement s'apprête à
en publier une nouvelle version antoine
quels sont les points à retenir pour le
moment
et alors hier il y avait une réunion au
ministère de la culture en présence de
roselyne bachelot gérald darmanin et des
professionnels de la presse donc comme
vous l'avez dit le gouvernement réagit
aux remarques du conseil d'état qui
avait en partie retoqué ce texte c'est
presque là une opération séduction des
journalistes qui se met en place du côté
du gouvernement si on s'en tient du
moins haut de page qui concerne
uniquement la presse et que nous avons
pu consulter donc par exemple il n'est
plus question que les gens n'aillent de
terrain se disperse lorsque l'ordre en
est donné par les forces de sécurité
dans une manifestation et c'est
contrairement à ce qui avait été prévu
justement dans le premier essai néo mots
de septembre 2020 de même le droit de
filmer ou de photographier les policiers
et les gendarmes dans le cadre de leur
travail et rappeler noir sur blanc dans
ce nouveau document donc comme pour
enterrer les polémiques qui était lié à
l'ancien article 24 de la loi pour une
sécurité globale cerise sur le gâteau
pour les journalistes spécialistes des
manifestations surtout il est inscrit
une bonne fois pour toutes qu'ils
peuvent circuler librement dans les
dispositifs de sécurité avec leurs
équipements de protection individuelle
donc on parle de casques de masques à
gaz par exemple ces matériels là ne
peuvent plus leur être confisquée et du
coup antoine avez-vous également
constaté un revers de la médaille à la
lecture du texte oui alors vous l'avez
senti pressenti des journalistes ne sont
évidemment pas 100% gagnant dans cette
affaire demant déjà on peut rappeler
tout simplement que le nouveau snm haut
ne fait que remettre des évidences sur
la table les journalistes ne sont là que
pour faire leur travail en manifestation
est pas pour causer des troubles lors
des opérations de maintien de l'ordre
mais ce n'est pas tout une source au
sein de la commission de la rue cette
commission qui a été chargé d'améliorer
les relations entre la presse et les
forces de l'ordre nous a fait savoir que
le gouvernement était surtout empressé
pour le moment de pousser les
représentants de la profession à faire
en sorte que chacun soit très bien
identifiés sur le terrain l'argument
utilisé semble simple sur le papier
s'ils veulent accéder à nos dispositifs
de sécurité les journalistes doivent
justifier de leur qualité
alors certes mais pour les journalistes
sans carte de presse et bien le cas
était pensée il était convenu de créer
une nouvelle attestation employeur dans
ces cas qui ne sont pas si rare et si un
pgi sans carte de presse ne sait pas
encore à qui va vendre ses images ce
n'est pas un cas rare non plus bien là
c'est le cas limites et une solution est
censé être trouvée pour eux d'ici le
mois de juillet prochain si je vous
comprends bien antoine le gouvernement
ne s'intéresseraient donc à créer
finalement une sorte de fichier de
journalistes autorisés alors on n'y est
pas tout à fait mais on en n'est plus
très loin c'est à dire qu' il y avait
l'idée qui flottait dans l'air à un
moment dans une espèce d'ordre des
journalistes et ça ne plaît pas du tout
à la profession en fait il ya une comme
un comité de suivi pour une bonne
application des 32 préconisations du
rapport de la rue donc cette commission
qui était censée améliorer les rapports
presse police et certaines de ses
préconisations était très favorable aux
journalistes et jean castex aussi bien
qu emmanuel macron on dit tous deux
qu'ils voulaient que tout cela se
traduit en actes c'était étonnant mais
en fait notre source au sein de la
commission de la rue nous a confié qu'il
y avait déjà eu quatre sessions de
travail uniquement sur cette seule
question de savoir comment identifier
les journalistes sur le terrain ce qui
en creux pourrait aussi permettre par
exemple d'exclure les journalistes sans
carte qu'on ne voudrait plus voir des
indésirables qu'une partie de la
profession une partie pourrait
s'accommoder de lâcher comme une
variable d'ajustement si vous voulez
mais bon dans tous les cas il s'agit en
fait toujours d'encadrer l'activité
journalistique merci et c'est aussi et
ce dont il était question hier au
ministère d'accueillir si beaucoup entre
deux bretelles pour aller plus loin je
me rappelle retrouve votre vos articles
sur le site rtl france points ps merci